[Música]
gracias por acompañarme una semana más
en medioambiente de france 24 iniciamos
el programa en estambul turquía a
finales del mes de junio se ha previsto
que comiencen las obras del canal de
estambul un mega proyecto de
infraestructura que el propio presidente
turco a pesar de haberlo propuesto el
mismo en 2011 cuando era primer ministro
del país ha calificado de loco son 45
kilómetros de canal que unirían de
manera artificial el mar negro al norte
con el mar de mármara al sur de la
ciudad más grande de europa respeta y
perdona no pretende así reducir el
tráfico marítimo por el bósforo la unión
natural entre ambos mares y por donde
pasan unos 48 mil barcos al año para
ponerlo en contexto el canal de panamá
tiene un tránsito anual de unos 14 mil
mientras el gobierno defiende su
proyecto alegando prosperidad económica
sus opositores alertan del peligro que
supone wta a los ecosistemas de la zona
a tan sólo 30 kilómetros al noroeste del
centro de estambul 350 hectáreas de
bosque tendrán que ser arrasadas además
el trazado del canal pasaría por la
presa de esas limosna una de las fuentes
de agua potable de la ciudad
el recorrido también afectaría lagos y
ríos que son lugar de tránsito de
cientos de aves migratorias pero los más
afectados serán los que viven en los
pueblos por los que pasaría el canal
nuestro corresponsal en turquía
adrià rocha habló con ellos
[Aplausos]
la vida de mira las ganadera en un
pequeño pueblo a las afueras de estambul
está a punto de cambiar
ahora mismo estamos en el pueblo de
backley paseando por nuestra granja con
los patos para que estén en el agua les
encantan
esta zona quedará soterrada bajo un
nuevo canal marítimo que quiere unir por
otra vía el mar negro y el mar de
mármara y crear un nuevo barrio de
estambul con cientos de miles de
habitantes
las obras arrasaron con varios pueblos
de la región dedicados a la agricultura
y la ganadería para dar paso a villas
centros comerciales residencias y
hoteles de lujo
[Música]
aun si el canal pasa por aquí nos
dejarán quedarnos
no no claro que no es imposible así es
como pasa en este tipo de proyectos
bueno con el cob y todo eso todo aquello
creo que ya no llegaré a ver el canal
buena parte de la población turca los
rivales de arrogante y el ayuntamiento
de estambul en manos opositoras se ha
lanzado en contra de este proyecto
vaticinan que será una catástrofe para
la ciudad más grande de europa
en nuestro plan medioambiental la ciudad
se ha llegado al máximo estipulado de
población de 15 ó 16 millones de
personas y quieren que lleguen uno y
medio o dos millones más de sus kits
el gobierno turco asegura que este nuevo
proyecto propuesto por el presidente
reyerta y perdón ayudará a limpiar el
bósforo la vía natural que parte
estambul por la mitad y uno de los
estrechos más famosos y transitados del
mundo otros están en completo desacuerdo
estoy en contra del proyecto porque
significará la destrucción total de la
ecología de estambul
somos stones dañar a muchos ecosistemas
dañar a la parte norte de la ciudad
donde están todos los bosques recursos
de agua dulce las zonas agrícolas y las
zonas rurales
mientras tanto los habitantes de la
región aguardan algunos han vendido sus
terrenos y se marchan otros como mira y
su familia se niegan
sirviendo mis tierras que trabajo voy a
hacer que hago a dónde voy nuestra
familia está aquí es del abuelo de mi
abuelo toda nuestra vida hemos trabajado
con los animales aquí si vendiese mos
nuestras tierras que podríamos hacer
este es nuestro sustento y les han dado
alguna alternativa
yo no ninguna alternativa
la moneda está en el aire y los
habitantes de la región no pueden hacer
más que esperar para que su destino sea
elegido su futuro y el de toda estambul
está a punto de cambiar para siempre
la apertura de una nueva unión esta vez
artificial entre el mar negro y el mar
de mármara supone además un peligro para
el equilibrio natural que existe ahora
entre ambos cuerpos de agua el marmara
es mucho más salado que el mar negro y
uno de los efectos del exceso de
salinidad hacia el norte podría ser que
las aguas se conviertan en anóxicas es
decir que se queden sin oxígeno esto
además de matar los ecosistemas marinos
tendría como consecuencia que la ciudad
oliera a huevos podridos un detalle que
no gustará ni a los 15 millones y medio
de habitantes de la antigua
constantinopla ni a los millones de
turistas que llegan cada año pese a las
advertencias de científicos y
ambientalistas el proyecto recibió el
visto bueno del ministerio de ambiente
de turquía en enero del año pasado un
ministerio que hay que decirlo es además
el de urbanización lo que pudo quizás
pues poner un año la pandemia de kobe 19
parece ser una realidad que según los
planes de erdogán estaría finalizada en
2023 y costaría entre 10.000 y 15.000
millones de dólares
y finalizamos con imágenes de una buena
noticia para la biodiversidad de las
plantas en el mundo regresaron a chile
844 cactus todos de especies poco
comunes y legalmente robados del
desierto de atacama las plantas fueron
devueltas por la policía militar de
italia que descubrió en 2020 este
cargamento en una casa de la localidad
de shen y galia una ciudad portuaria en
el mar adriático los cactus tuvieron que
esperar un año para regresar a chile por
la pandemia de kobe 19 pero la espera
valió la pena ya que según los expertos
las plantas no habrían sobrevivido en
italia ahora tendrán que pasar 4 meses
de cuarentena en un centro especial a
las afueras de santiago está aún por
decidir si los cactus volverán al
desierto de atacama o si los llevarán al
jardín botánico de la capital donde
tendrán que reproducir sus condiciones
naturales con estas imágenes me despido
nos vemos la semana que viene
y
[Música]